in five four three two one
what's up everybody you [ __ ]
motherless fatherless sons of [ __ ]
nobody loves you except for us hey only
only genius brain cares about you
everybody else who said I love you
they're [ __ ] lying
we're your only families you lonely
[ __ ] sound like a cult sup everybody
so we today we have a very very special
guest today we have the Benny
big balls baby big balls Betty Lou the
man behind the publication editorial
next shark so if you guys have seen JK
news we actually do bring up a lot of
like next shark articles you guys are
pretty much on on almost every JK thank
you for that we use JK yeah and also on
Instagram you guys get [ __ ] shared a
lot man a lot of the memes that you guys
start and all that the news yeah so what
next shark is if you guys haven't seen
it or heard of it it's a agen American
centric kind of news what right would
you say yeah yeah I would say that we
focus a lot on I guess the Asian
American community have you heard of
this other they're called Asian boss
yeah the agent in there Asia based right
yeah and there are they're all based in
Asia I don't I've met the founders
before wanna Steven I forgot the other
guy's name okay
okay and so those are the two main are
they from Malaysia or you don't know cuz
they do record like from Japan to
everywhere yeah yeah they're purely uh
age' base I mean they're fun they're
also funded by I believe a investment
fund based in a Korea too so they're
just all kinds of Asian teaching Chung
ethnic dude that's tight they had
because I only mentioned is because I
just mentioned it's on the last podcast
that we did it's hardcore
where they asked their see Baloo was
like ugly oh yeah it was like yeah these
girls are mean yeah do they did not Wow
yeah he's not ugly he's just not Asian
pretty yeah I think it's like yeah what
the [ __ ] dude they they act like he's
[ __ ] Shrek or something yeah I mean
one go gave him a 3.5
like dude this hideous at a 10 yeah that
bars I don't know how how what their bar
is are no Heidi yeah I don't know are
they looking for k-pop stars like
because I know that Asian celebs are
just Asian standards in Asia is
different like their their beauty
standards are different you know I will
say this the the meanest one there that
was just [ __ ] going and on him she
did have a point though not about how
ugly he is cuz he's a very handsome man
it was more like she says that it's
insulting that they are using Asian
culture things to grab a bigger Asian
audience but they don't ask Asian people
about their preferences about who they
want the star to be and so because a lot
of Marvel's ticket sales are based in
Asia they they sell a [ __ ] ton there so
her point was that how come you guys
based like these these beauty standards
or what you think that handsome Asian
man should be if that's like your thing
to get us to go but you don't cater it
towards Asian people in Asia she must
live here yeah so why would and he goes
who is this guy if he's if he's somebody
that's famous only in the United States
he goes well we have stars in China that
are internationally well known yeah like
fake they could bring a bigger audience
and we you sell so much stuff over here
how come that's not put into
consideration so I kind of understood
where she was coming from with that
yeah cuz it's totally different Asian
American cultures different from Asian
Asia culture yeah the challenges are
different too yeah because you know here
like we deal with the whole you know
experience with racism and how we're
kind of perceived in the media whereas
an Asian I mean they're the majority
yeah so they don't really had they don't
really have to deal with those issues
and in the contrast isn't as big when
you're compared to European and West
America or America right so like if
there's a hot like French actor or like
a British actor or whatever the standard
of beauty is pretty damn similar right
so but then for us it's it's it's almost
like a whole different world yeah it's
it's different because I think like
Asian American style too just it's not
that we're trying to look black or white
or anything but our tastes it just
develops differently because it's so
multicultural yes so then I feel like
Asian American girls are prettier than
Asian girls in Asia even though they
have their own style I think yeah it's
cool and all but yeah
I don't know you know it like that
Chinese style do the girls with the
[ __ ] white ass faces the pink
lipstick and the yellow teeth through
the cutest [ __ ] girls that look like
they don't even eat anything Sumeria
there was a huge thing in issue they
wanted that thigh gap [ __ ]
yeah and that's you know it kind of came
here for the crazy challenges and stuff
yeah gap [ __ ] they want like virtually
no muscle musculature in their legs or
some [ __ ] I'm not sure if that's a pop
thing now but that's what I remember
when I was young there were rap like
dollar bills like if it wraps all around
like it's like some weird [ __ ] did and
right now the hot thing in like Korea
and Japan I'm not sure if it's in China
but it's like peach lipstick with peach
rosy cheeks and really Boyle faces like
it's like that's like the hot make up
thing and I don't know why but when we
were in Japan all the girls look like
that yeah they want to look like cute
cute dolls yeah and for me I feel like a
molester there they look like children
yeah I mean like their idea of cute like
it's too cute to the point where there's
no in my opinion there's no sex appeal
yeah but it yeah
but in Asian American women like they
they there's like a level of this sexual
maturity to them like it's more Western
like their clothes their even their body
type like there's more protein you know
I mean like there's curves and there's
just you know shoutouts to the Asian
girls in Houston
y'all got ass right fantastic I wish I
could just fall asleep and bury myself
in it yeah but the thing is if they're
in Asia they look so fat yeah they're
fat why you so fat yeah there's a vice
article of like lazy this woman that was
just like oh like everyone I went back
to China like people were thought it was
okay to call me fat people on the
streets well yeah you know and so I mean
yeah it looks crazy those like you know
you know how like some Asian parents or
Chinese parents when I grew up I mean it
was very normal if you see like a family
member and you call you fat yeah there's
call you fat hey you got fatter I think
as an agent thank God man yeah yeah this
is the most annoying thing I would
always get right because I was so fat
for the majority of my life they come up
and they're like dude you're so fat you
need to stop eating less and that will
stop eating they're like well you don't
like my food like eat some more can't
win I'm like what do you want from me
you [ __ ] Psychopaths
do you want me not to either you want me
to [ __ ] eat it and then they pile my
plate to the [ __ ] top and to the brim
of every [ __ ] side of the plate and
everything fat shame you again after I
don't know what you want from me man
like it's like damned if I do damned if
I don't so I was like whatever [ __ ] it
I'll just eat everything the cool thing
was like at church though every Sunday
at my Korean church they would have a
potluck type of thing after sermon is
[ __ ] and then they would they we you go
through the line and they would put all
this like [ __ ] punch on side dishes
and they would put it on my plate they
would look how big I am ago oh let me
put some more like damn straight they're
not that [ __ ] there by jealousy mean
[ __ ] nothing you wish you were fat
[ __ ] that's so [ __ ] well you
started off originally doing uh we were
talking about a for new media rockstars
when I first met you mm-hmm no actually
it was the other Asians remember oh that
was before new media
yeah those before yeah that's how I met
him actually back in what the thing with
Benny is you've been always doing stuff
for the Asian community like just behind
the scenes yeah I know you know it's
like pushing pop culture for us and [ __ ]
yeah I've always been really passionate
and I mean I grew up in San Francisco
two Chinese immigrants and everything
and went through that whole Asian pride
phase cuz I was huge and you know the
major yeah upper cap lower cap with the
AZN pretty much what was your [ __ ]
email on your screen name bro oh my god
you know it had such a corny ass like I
just say right I was also I used to
break dance back in elementary school to
middle school yeah it was such a cheesy
name it was my screen or just bend the
breaker so there was no like AZN or
theirs is better than ours then dude it
was yours mine was like [ __ ] Korean
panda bear then it was like it was like
Asian some XI I can't remember but then
like I also had like everybody used to
call me Panda so like it was just it
just stuck because I was a big fat asian
guy right so all my emails had the word
Panda hmm that was like your nickname
yeah that's cool
what about you Joe was your screen name
damn Joe shut up
what does everybody say to me just funny
but before that like I never had that a
ZN thing cuz i got in early early to a
AOL and then like i wanted to be like
this [ __ ] and wannabe hacker and [ __ ]
so like i did the upper case lower case
but my name was apex no oh like next
level with it and then i got into the
whole asian [ __ ] i didn't know that
asian people like existed when you were
around like blacks Mexicans and then I
was online I was just looking at [ __ ]
texts like I didn't you know I didn't
know that there was a [ __ ] ton of Asians
in LA until I moved yeah when I uh when
I used to work at the Men's Wearhouse so
when you when you you weren't there
Men's Wearhouse yeah you still work at
the men's where I used to sell and fit
people for tuxedos and suits just so I
was like a wardrobe [ __ ] guy and so
[ __ ] uh dudes like these old og Asian
dudes would like sign up for the kids to
get their stuff but the funny [ __ ] is
like they haven't changed their email in
ages so it's like this guy that looks
proper as [ __ ] but this says Asian
gangbanger 96 you know at yahoo.com
[ __ ] it's like a Z and ugh boy
sweet face so they're they're very
they're well they were always
apprehensive about writing an email they
go oh do we have to write emails like
yeah that would be the best way unless
you wants to call you dying language
somebody Falls going off I said my phone
oh yeah but anyways so you're okay what
what got you to start your first public
8 like what is it is it a blog first
yeah like yeah we got to go back to like
the other age yeah that was your
original yes so my background has always
been you know man I don't even know what
my background is at this point that did
so much stuff you know I mean I would
say I started off like as an internet
marketer towards the end of college oh
[ __ ] yeah and so I was doing a lot of
like cool campaigns I did a had a couple
big clients and did a couple projects
with like you know billboard MGM and
McDonald's and then you know through
some of my friends and I went to college
with you know Mellie Mellie Lee guys you
know know she is shoutouts to Mellie Lee
you know great photographer
he is drunk I've ever met him she's
awesome but I got [ __ ] stories about
her she's [ __ ] hilarious
no she's great she's like you know I
definitely love her to death you know
definitely I consider her as family but
yeah you know went to school with her
and through mutual friends you know we
met Julie's on you know who's now an
actress and you know really successful
and everything shoutouts to Julie's on
also crazy [ __ ]
that [ __ ] got cocaine running through
her blood a sober sober that's the crazy
[ __ ] she hustles so hard man seriously
like I respect her a lot yeah you know
but yeah I mean they they both
approached me and uh like hey you know
we want to start like just a blog for
fun just to showcase you know profiling
asian-americans and non stereotypical
you know careers and everything cuz you
know we're kind of pushed because of the
model minority or whatever we'll kind of
push more towards you know more
conservative you know jobs like medical
lawyer all that stuff right which is
great yeah I don't know why people hate
it I'm like man that's a great thing
that for a culture yeah you want people
doing respectable [ __ ] I think there's a
list of what you're passionate in right
yeah that's true yeah I never I think
like thee because I never grew up with
that thing so like I I didn't know till
later I didn't know that was a problem
like this when somebody was like oh
you're gonna be a doctor lawyer sight in
your face I'm dumb dude but I'm like
that's tight that you think that you
copping off of my paper joke's on you I
didn't even study homie just like me
stupid in your face yeah I wish I
understood the whole problem with the
what's it called model minority thing
right you grew up multicultural like in
Sacramento I I mean similar to me right
like I think that's why we all vibe like
I grew up in gardena there is a there is
a handful of Asians there but then it's
it's like lower you know income kind of
like middle-class damn see while I'm
talking about Laurie
yeah and for timing I was blind to what
the majority of Asians were like so dead
there would be a handful of agender kids
or whatever but there would be a good
enough amount of other kinds of gory
yeah [ __ ] like athletes or whatever
and so cool Asian kids and whatever so
um I was until like later and even when
I went to a predominantly Asian
neighborhood which is Monterey Park but
moderate part you know Asians are the
majority yeah yeah and it was like the
it was like a [ __ ] breeding ground
for Asian gangs back when I wasn't I was
like growing up but um I never felt this
like thing until college and then I
started doing shows and then I started
to meet other Asian kids all over
America and I was like well this is the
majority I'm the minority like this is
I'm the weird one cuz I always used to
watch TV and being like whoo [ __ ] are
these Asian guys like this is some
[ __ ] fake ass made up yeah yeah but I
was like oh wait no that's actually what
most Asians are I'm the wrong one yeah
that's interesting it's where you grew
up man yeah yeah that's interesting yeah
so yeah that's that's awesome that you
guys were doing that with the other
Asians you wanted to showcase like
artists entertainers just kind of out of
the ordinary doctor engineer kind of
stuff right yeah pretty much I mean we
saw like this like trend of like you
know back then a lot of like Asian
creators were making a Bigfoot footprint
onto YouTube and everything and so I
would say I would argue that a big
portion of YouTube stars at the time
were you know Asians and Asian America
they were huge yeah hell yeah 2007 yeah
man we had like the top three we had
what it was ryan higa ryan higa KevJumba
raywilliamjohnson
you know like the Gambino's and you know
like it's because it requires you to
understand how to use a computer that's
why if I could envision people baby do
we're innovators man we had you know we
were on aim we
yeah I mean come on friend stir all that
stuff man we race books
Facebook's all that all that stuff you
know even early adopters in technology
that's for sure so yeah yeah I mean back
then when YouTube was very early that's
yeah it was [ __ ] awesome because
that's also where we were able to get
our foot in the door and entertainment
yeah you guys through you Jake I mean
you know I I was a fan of you know JK
news and everything I mean just kidding
films no at the time and everything and
so it was really just cool kind of like
seeing you know so many Asian Americans
do their thing and you know gain a big
following because of it and you guys not
only had Asian fans you guys had you
know a multitude yeah multi culture I'd
like for us to we're just very like I
think we've always just been like
outsiders and a lot of stuff because we
never really we never really actually
got involved into YouTube community
right we actually just kind of stuck
within our own little nucleus in our own
yeah you know and then we just kind of
hear things to the grapevine about
what's happening to YouTube you know so
that was the weird part people like oh
like I would go to a lot of these
YouTube events and people Albee it would
be very offended when they they come up
was like oh I was hanging out with this
person I'm like who's that I was trying
to be cool I don't [ __ ] know who you
are you're like I don't know who you are
have asked me a lot yeah it's like I
remember the first time I came to
actually shoutouts to a Tom know but I
met Tom yeah and then Tom was like oh I
represent KevJumba at the time I'm like
I have no idea who that is bro I need
that I think he kind of thought I was an
[ __ ] but I was like I don't know who
the [ __ ] that is dude I don't know who
this guy names like I also represent
Joseph Vincent I was like who the [ __ ]
is that at the time love you Joseph but
when I didn't know him and so people I
think they kind of had this thing of oh
because you're Asian American on YouTube
you should know who these Asian people
are but I didn't like I only knew them
yeah yeah I mean cuz well in your
defense you're trying to be a stand-up
comedian exactly was anything and so he
just did YouTube just to [ __ ] around and
when we met like he was still on his
trajectory like to be a stand-up
comedian he just used YouTube as a way
to do things he was in a youtuber you
know he did YouTube rants or whatever it
was just stand-up comedy bits yeah and
so like I think like as we became closer
and friends that we were like you should
just be on YouTube because that stand-up
[ __ ] is going to be a really
hard grind yeah and so we all kind of
embraced it I think we come from the
generation of being a youtuber is kind
of like looked down upon and it's not
respectable kinda yeah what's crazy you
know it's cool like the kids that grew
up watching us they're like I want to be
a youtuber when I grew up grow up or
whatever and I'm like oh that's because
we couldn't get in Hollywood you know
yeah like my friends kids they'll be in
school and you know when you're in
elementary school they'll ask what you
want to be when you're older and kids
will put YouTuber as a career path what
a weirdo saying it is such an odd
concept to that that that's a career
choice and it's weird because like I
always tell people um like YouTube he's
an easy man that shit's [ __ ] rough I
think they see a lot of the stuff and
they think like oh I could do it too I
was like well just like any other career
if you could do it you would have done
it by now you have to be kind of like I
mean it's great to try it's great to do
it for fun too but I think to make it
into a career is the hard part all right
I don't you don't know how sustainable
it is dedication to it I think the way
that people go about their YouTube
career - there's a reason why a lot of
these guys come in to disappear really
fast no there's like three four years
and they're gone it's because they tried
to do as much as they could whenever
they could and they didn't really have
any content they just kept stealing from
other people's ideas and after a while
that well dries up yeah and they go well
what now and the problem with the
younger with with I think a younger
youtubers is that they identify
themselves based on what other people
think about them so they don't really
create because not all of them but a
good handful and don't create because
they want to create yeah I think yeah
but it's hard because like I think that
it's a weird system now because I think
that when you're when you get a viral
video you get a viral hit like you see
all numbers and those numbers it's like
validation for you right yeah and so you
know if you're creating
yeah these numbers are great I mean you
know we just got to keep doing these
sort of things and I think that if you
go down that path is really easy to kind
of lose sight of you know why you're
doing this in the first place because
now you're like oh I'm doing it
naturally you kind of just Alton fall
into whatever the numbers might take you
I think that's kind of cool like when I
think maybe it's because I didn't start
off trying to do YouTube fully it's just
whenever I put up a video if it did well
I was all that's dope if it
didn't do well is this kind of like is
what it is and I would move on and would
do another one right just because I
never really held anything too precious
there's not there's rarely anything I've
ever put up on YouTube that I thought
was perfect I was like it's gonna go up
on YouTube this is good for what it is
you're not the type to delete an
Instagram photo cuz you didn't get
enough life absolutely not dude like
I'll just leave it on there you know
just like it is what it is I have asked
everything it's it's it's a weird weird
space to be in man like it's evolved a
lot I mean especially like especially I
feel like for editorial stuff like you
guys do
it's editorial stuff is hyper going into
like video and like they're opening up
video and digital branches yeah actually
what's crazy is that I read an article
today like they surveyed about like a
thousand teens or something and I think
it was like I forgot the number it was
over 50% so I think it was like 60 or
70% of them said that they get their
news from YouTube and not like YouTube
not like you - in terms of like CNN
YouTube but like you know YouTube
personalities and you know celebrities
influenceable
yup I oh that yeah you gotta go into
video like I mean in Instagram I bet you
get a lot traffic from Instagram cuz
people are [ __ ] passing around your
[ __ ] or like tagging their friends or
whatever right but the memes I think
that's how people consume news now is
they just either they [ __ ] see memes
real quick like the the clips yeah
Facebook you know like I mean if
anyone's watching TV and is dangerous
territory because like sometimes like
you know news you you can't dumb down
certain pieces of news by one photo or
like one meme you know there's so many
different nuances and stuff so it gets
into dangerous territory yeah you know
so it's it's a struggle that we that way
you need to figure out - or I mean I
think what's cool about you though is
that you try to keep it a little
old-school and what I mean by that is I
don't think people understand like
old-school journalism and news is just
reporting and in you're trying you're
not trying to do an angle unless you're
that's that's propaganda you know like
that's that's that's just not good
journalism that's an opinion piece or
whatever right but that's the nature of
what the world is today because you know
like all these media like big-ass moguls
are trying to catch up to what someone
on the floor with Twitter can do like if
you see some
shooting just went down you could just
[ __ ] record it on your phone and just
upload but he's a journalist now you got
anybody can be a journalist and you can
just be popular off a blog or you could
just be a personality and a vlogger and
be a political vlog or a news vlogger
you know and then it's like they're
beating all these guys yeah so then what
do they have to do they they don't have
time to research they don't have to like
there used to be checks and balances you
know like if you want it to publish
something yet to go and like you have
your chief editor and then he checks and
then you have to check your sources and
all that a source a lot of lines of
verification before you report on
something even then and sometimes you
could be wrong too even after all that
work yeah but now it's because of that
speed that all this like mainstream
media is trying to do they're getting
into a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] dude because
their [ __ ] lives over like they're
they're going based off of like oh [ __ ]
I don't even know where this info comes
from but then like I better beat the
punch like I get the clicks yeah and
then people are being wrongly accused of
certain things and being dogged and all
that stuff and I'm like that's crazy
yeah the addiction to the numbers I mean
you know I don't I I think it's uh it's
it's tough I mean I don't I don't think
there's you know people are out right
out there do bad [ __ ] but you know
sometimes like when you see certain
numbers and you're subconsciously become
like oh maybe this is the right way to
go maybe this is you know what we should
be doing I don't even know if people are
writing now just to get information now
especially as like I don't know like I
mean there's a lot of people who are
great and I'm just saying from the stuff
that I see that blows up like the
journalistic integrity kind of
disappears for things that blow up a lot
right so for example there was something
the article about I forego who wrote it
but it was something about like it was
literally an opinion piece about you
know adults shouldn't go to Disneyland
incite millennial Chenault yeah really
write that cuz you think that or did you
write that because you wanted to start
some [ __ ] up right because the you know
just reading it was like this is just
it's stupid it's idiotic you know I mean
so I look at that I'm like this person
literally just write this just so people
can click it you bet you that did really
well to it cuz I saw because I don't
look at anything you know it's like how
do I like [ __ ] pander how do I get
yeah how do I make these people angry
and then it'll go viral or like you know
yep ending two groups together or
something
you know trying to get that debate going
on yeah because real journalism could
get boring man this podcast is brought
to you by Skillshare Beibei that is the
official song for Skillshare i don't
care what you say yes this podcast is
brought to you by Skillshare my friends
and we're talking about lifelong
learning we're talking about learning
outside of just college high school
junior high or even some of you
elementary school students alright but
we want to take lifelong learning and
just make it accessible for people and
that's what Skillshare does Skillshare
allows you to learn a lot of the stuff
that you want to learn outside of just
an institutionalized place such as
college and do it at your own pace there
are a lot of things that we want to
learn at on our own time and there's a
lot of things that we want to learn
outside of what college can teach us in
a very quick and accessible way and
that's what Skillshare has so Skillshare
is an online learning community with
thousands of amazing classes covering
dozens of creative and entrepreneurial
skills so whether you're returning to a
long time passion project challenging
yourself to get outside your comfort
zone or simply exploring something new
Skillshare has classes for you the
classes that i consistently take or the
lessons that i always go into always
have to do around with a photography and
videography and Skillshare has a bunch
of stuff like that
so for me it's really applicable to my
life because of what I do for a living
so check out Skillshare and you will
love it as much as I love it people so
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for my listeners to
get two months of Skillshare for free
that's right Skillshare is offering
genius brain listeners two months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for free to sign up go to skill show.com
slash brain again go to Skillshare comm
slash brain to start your two months now
that's Skillshare comm slash b are a I n
that's why how do you find that balance
because I've noticed that about next
shark is that you guys don't do that you
you you just report yeah we do our best
to try to stay like as balanced as
possible
but at the same time you know for us you
know we aim to be the voice of global
Asian that's kind of like what our
tagline
right and so you know in terms of that
we kind of just want to offer a platform
to showcase different points of view
because Asian Americans and you know
Asians in general like they're not this
you know they don't believe in the same
things there's a lot of cultural
differences all sizes - yeah see I like
that about you because you're showing
that we're not a monolith like there's
Asian conservatives there's a shin
libertarians there's Asian and liberals
there's you know there's so many
different schools of thought and even
within the culture you could be Japanese
American Chinese premier whatever like
in their slight differences and all that
stuff right so people don't think and
feel the same exact thing but there's
other groups out there who want to speak
for us as if like as an asian-american
this is how we feel and I'm like [ __ ] no
I don't agree you know that's why I
never come out like you know I think
that there's a obviously there certain
like you know Asian activists and you
know you know hats off to them for
everything that they do and you know
they come out and that you know they say
hey you know we speak for whatever but
you know for me I've always kind of just
like to be behind the scenes because I
don't speak for all Asian Americans you
know I don't know I don't I don't want
to you know and there's so many things
that I still don't know right and so all
I can really do it's like hey um you
know we offer a platform and if you guys
have like you know some interesting
thoughts you know and if there's certain
news that that needs to be shine upon
within your community I mean that's
something that we want to you know offer
that to you guys and people I you know
did like you said everybody can be a
journalist and people with the biggest
chip on their shoulders right some of
the trashiest things I've ever seen in
my life man like I'm as somebody who
wanted to do a documentary on the the
the white takeover of matcha right and
so having a conversation with this
person on oh we should do it because
then we could we can make them feel like
you know they're matcha stores
inauthentic yeah they were the most
authentic one yeah this person was
talking about it's like oh yeah like oh
when people drink matcha they shouldn't
just drink it however they want this is
a ceremonial thing and I'm like nah bro
like you're talking about some ancient
ass
[ __ ] in Japan they [ __ ] do much of
like favorite ice cream and you know
exactly so [ __ ] are you so like I'm so
this person this Asian person has a huge
chip on their shoulder and I was like
you're gonna do a docu-series about
garbage because I said it's not even
true
I was like have you been to Japan like
literally you'll see [ __ ] like matcha
flavored condoms for crying out loud you
know ice cream yeah it's like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about but people
sometimes when they had this huge chip
on their shoulders they they like to
make their personal feelings into facts
and it kind of sucks right so it's like
like that type of thing - cuz we own a
matcha store you know and well we we
kind of made these drinks very fun
because what we learned when we went to
Japan it's like the farmers that
actually make our matcha they just make
sure there are water that [ __ ] and they
drink it up you know to me yeah you know
and so I'm like what the [ __ ] is this
person's problem right it's not like the
best way to handle it - the best way to
take it to a lot of in Japan don't drink
matcha on a regular like the ceremonial
style because there's a whole [ __ ]
thing behind it it's like going to yoga
class for [ __ ] tea do you know
whatever you are yukata and everything
it's like what are you talking about
and dude it's so funny because I was
talking to one of the farmers out there
that he's you know he's uh we used the
distributor and then I was like so what
made like this whole dessert matcha
thing popular he goes I think it's
actually Westerners and we're like what
and goes yeah you know like it was the
matcha craze kind of started dying down
in Japan and then you know Westerners
started doing like lattes and things
like that and then he's like yeah it's
kind of cool it's reviving the whole
like excitement for matcha again and and
so it's like everything we're global man
everything is just always being
influenced by each other and to be so
[ __ ] rigid about how this culture
owns this thing is I think it's a little
weird well you're not gonna win that
[ __ ] battle everything is global now
right yeah so I mean just think about
something very small like this when I go
to let's say Hawaii or something right
there like get me a souvenir from
someone Hawaii I was like you can go to
a marketing it the same [ __ ] that I got
in Hawaii right in LA you don't need me
to bring anything back you know I stop
and get my own souvenirs because of that
reason I stopped doing it because I
would go in and I'd just be like oh made
in China made in China made in China oh
[ __ ] I saw the same like get Mac nuts
well you could get at Costco it's like
what
yeah you special chips it's like whoa I
saw it at the [ __ ] market the other
day like yeah yeah there's nothing
special anymore I can bring it back on
it's it's like handmade oh yeah like I
my favorite thing was Hokkaido chips I
like all I got I need to go to Hokkaido
and get these chips and then it's on
Amazon okay the one thing I do miss this
oh there's just like little chocolate
that I get in Japan that mariel
introduce my fiancee it's called Black
Thunder right sounds like black like a
black guy's dick but it's just our name
is cheap chocolate right and you can get
him like in any [ __ ] like convenience
store in Japan and it's [ __ ] I love
it it's like their version of crackle
right I tried getting it online on
Amazon a box was like 30-something bucks
I was like [ __ ] man like I should have
just bought a shit-ton over there near
the International shipping or something
yeah yeah [ __ ] piss me off man I was
like to do so there's got to be some
kind of like responsibility that comes
along with that daunting task of wanting
to be the place for I guess an Asian
voice of course it's a it's a big
responsibility and so is it like Asian
voices in Western countries or what your
guys is like real model here I think
that majority of our team is in America
obviously so we do cover a lot of Asian
American news and we cover a lot of news
from like a Western Asians you know
viewpoint Minna sense right and you know
the whole premise of next shark has been
just very it's been very very organic I
mean I don't know if you guys know but
it started off as an entrepreneur site
for Millennials I remember that I like
that a lot because it spoke to me yeah
yeah exactly and you know we did well
for a little bit but it wasn't we didn't
do it it wasn't at a scale where like
wow we could really like you know make a
living off of this or whatever right and
we were just trying to figure out okay
well what's you know what's what's our
angle what do we do right but then we
noticed that a lot of our Asian centric
content was doing well us whenever we
showed like an Asian entrepreneur or
like technology in Asia we saw like an
uptick in you know traffic and you know
just people sharing or content online
and for some reason to smoke out to them
so really okay let's do a little bit
more of that and so all of a sudden we
became kind of like okay let's let's
focus on Asian faces Asian business
is you know more slightly towards Asian
and I started doing really well and then
this is 2016 that's when the Rio
Olympics happened right and then we
started getting all these DMS you know
going hey um you know there's a lot of
Asian athletes of Asian descent
participating in the Olympics and you
guys should cover them because you know
there isn't as much visibility for these
athletes and so we were like okay it's
not really in our you know wheelhouse
but we can give it a shot yeah and then
our coverage like blew up like crazy I
mean even little things like we covered
something like we didn't even break the
story it was a like all the other
mainstream publications already released
it like Vietnam wins their you know
first Olympic gold medal or something
right oh the guy with the gun the
Sharpshooter I think so yeah I think so
yeah so I mean I remember just the
weekend I'm just like you know I you
know at the time I was still like doing
you know writing too and so I remember
just a weekend I just did a quick ride
upon and enough Sun and it was like you
know 500 hits and less than 24 hours I
was crazy you know and so many people
were sharing it and everything and then
a couple months later the we started
getting more DMS going hey like crimes
against asian-americans are some of the
lowest like reported like you guys
should cover more that stuff and so your
fan base actually just created the
content for you yeah you gave them what
they were just asking for yeah we just
you know cuz for us I mean I think that
is important to kind of listen to your
readers and to figure out kind of like
you know what you know what is what is
it that they you know kind of want and
one one to kind of consume and we kind
of base it off of that and so you know I
always give shoutouts to you know a lot
of our readers and supporters is a
reason why I like you know this is why
I'm here today honestly because all I
did was just listen and you know listen
to feedback I try my best to you know
read you know the PM's and read the
emails like even to this day and so you
our staff know what was that article
about crimes against asian-americans are
at least was that mean I'm just like you
know for example like oh how do you say
it like let's say the whole dr-dos
situation remember like you know so that
one actually like really really put us
on the map I mean you know when that a
Vietnamese I guess Vietnamese American a
doctor was dragged off this forcibly
dragged a flight you know there was like
bloodied and everything and again we
weren't the only we weren't the only
publication
port on it I mean tons of publication
reported beforehand but because we built
such a solid Asian following at the time
there was this like analytics company
that was just like trying to rank how
much engagement a Facebook post got
based on a certain subject and so when
they were ranking based on the subject
surrounding this next shark actually
ranked our coverage ranked number three
across Facebook wow it's crazy like we
beat I saw we beat out New York Post and
they're like all these major
publications under us I was like wow
this is crazy I mean you know it's so
the stories are right I mean I feel like
you know they it's one of those things
where they don't really get to see the
sort of coverage like anywhere else and
so this is kind of a space where they
can kind of go you know discuss these
issues and to kind of share what's going
around locally mmm Danny I'm sure we
share a fan base because we always use
your guys's articles for JK news
appreciate that Batman and it's because
I genuinely care about and then they're
they're interesting they're funny and
there's it's not I mean there's there's
so much variety to it you know you got
fashion you got music you got fun you
got and it doesn't get too political
like like that's what I like about it is
I think nowadays you have to choose a
side like you can't be a news media
outlet that does you know you that does
balanced sides yeah there's gotta be
either left or right yeah and you know
for us like this is what we'd say I mean
if anybody ever says asks us us you know
what what are you politically aligned or
whatever and you know obviously you know
as a publication we have to say yeah we
keep trying to keep us balanced as
possible but it's no secret I mean like
our image if you look at a majority of
our staff like a majority of them are
definitely more so like left-leaning
right but you know how we kind of try to
balance it out is like you know we don't
try to shun people that don't really
believe in you know what believe in our
beliefs um but we've had like Trump
supporter Asian Trump supporters write
op-eds on our page and we've gotten
flack for it but at the same time it's
kind of like you know look so many
people voted for you know so many people
voted for Trump you know and you can't
tell me that you know they don't have
like some sort of a voice you know and
so I think that it's important to at
least try to create a dialogue of some
sort you know yeah and we don't know
it's the whole thing is not perfect
right I mean there's still like a long
way to go to figure out where that
the Librium is and everybody's just
trying to figure out like how to reach
that equilibrium yeah that's something I
can stand by cuz I think JK news we try
to do the same thing where I mean at the
end of the day we're not genius
philosophers we're just there to [ __ ]
around and talk [ __ ] but at the same
time I feel like we'd have a fan base
that is both like liberal and
conservative and some people get they
feel left out if we lean too much on one
side or the other and I think most of us
don't care enough like we'll care like I
like the way I look at politics is like
like WWE and like drama and like
entertainment like to me I don't take it
as serious as other people and I like to
argue so it might sound like I'm just
really about something but I just argue
for the sake of argument sometimes cuz
it's fun but I have to remember that
people take this [ __ ] serious and this
is something that is like someone's life
you know and in and so I try to do that
but I also want the goal is like the
common ground thing and it's like what
where is there a place where they can
agree or maybe even find a compromise
because the way that this country is
going to it's it's it's a lot of these
like people just in their own bubbles
and saying we'll [ __ ] these guys these
guys are they don't know anything they
don't have the right data they're all
[ __ ] brainwashed and the more we
separate like that it just creates chaos
yeah it's it's it's it's hard man I mean
it's it's we're worthless we're in this
stage where there's just like no room
for nuance right it's either like you're
either here or yeah you're not with us
then you know screw you don't think I
think people just they say they don't
like labels but they [ __ ] love labels
dude they like groups they like being
grouped up into a group and they like
pointing fingers are saying I'm better
than you that's like that's generally
look what people have like that's the
same thing with even like let's say if
we were to bring it down like to earth
you tomb in Hollywood right there's
always this concept of like I'm better
than you like my I'm a content creator
you're over you're sucking Hollywood's
dick and then these people are like you
don't even make real movies you know but
it's like why can't people just be happy
doing what they're doing is you know why
is good people like labels they like it
they there's this thing where people are
going on right now they're like oh don't
label me this this and that but you just
say but you [ __ ] love it that's why
you I love it as fun they like
like the identity and the feeling of
belonging in a certain group yeah I like
to feel like I'm better than people
that's true so I'm like [ __ ] those
Hollywood [ __ ] how many dicks
did yet to suck to be in a move a lot of
dicks but then they get like 20 million
dollar [ __ ] roll and I'm like jealous
oh yeah for sure it's hard man you got
to go to the Oscars sit next to Lil Jon
music anymore but he's hanging out Jon
dude no I mean like um they're probably
sit in the back somewhere you know like
with the with the see lists and be lists
not in the front yeah
did you always want to go into like
journalism no dude you know what the
funny thing is in college you know I got
like I think I tested still have like a
high school reading level like I'm dumb
ass dude like it's looking funny it's
crazy dude it's funny because my parents
had that whole thing where it's like oh
you know Benny's gonna be when I was
born they had this high bar for me where
it's like oh man he's gonna be a doctor
someday no I could see it in his face
he's gonna be he's gonna really save
lives and stuff right yeah but I go to
the kindergarten they had they realize
they had to lower their bar like crazy
that's [ __ ] as soon as you got to
kindergarten you've made him lose hope
that is [ __ ] hilarious first
parent-teacher conference I remember
like you know during spelling test you
supposed I don't know how it was for you
guys are in kindergarten right but when
we took spelling tests right you know
you take a piece of paper there weren't
desks at the time for some reason there
was small desk but we have to kind of
pick a corner and you know kind of
listen to the teacher I was one of those
kids I was just drawing on my item I
didn't pay attention I don't know what's
going on I was so oblivious to what was
going on [ __ ] funny so I just like I
was literally so by the time everybody
handed in their their you're spelling
tests is like I'd have pictures all over
mine and then so and I remember like the
bar was so low that at the end of the
year like you know how they give you
poor cards they write comments and all
right but yeah Benny's really improved I
mean he stopped talking food they were
like oh you know yeah Benny's really
improved you know he stopped talking
when I talk he doesn't make weird noises
like you know in the corner he
understands that timeout is a
you know it's a punishment now it's not
you know room to just like I said I grew
around and everything it was so low and
so funny every like you know should you
not like every single year up until I
went to high school during
parent-teacher conference one time it
was the same exact conversation I know
it was like oh hey Benny we might need
to hold Benny back a grade you know like
he's really struggling things aren't
working out same exact conversation if
for some reason I always just barely
like you know I just barely made it
every single time up until actually even
up until college I just barely made it
like you know graduated from UC Irvine
right and you know I I but you still got
in the UCI though that's pretty amazing
ya know it's like it's crazy Oh talk
about like you know good investments or
a big appeals before when I when UC
Irvine was like a safety school you know
like it was it was like it was like you
Riverside yeah and then yeah he was like
nobody was like that it was a safety
school man oh really cuz I didn't get
the nerve I only got in the Riverside Oh
forever well I had like a 2.6 GPA so I
barely hit the minimum - you imply to
UCS oh I did really poor in school did
you see Riverside thing or no I went to
UC Riverside yeah they took everybody so
a little my SAT scores were really good
though it's like I went to Cal State LA
nice
sure cuz it was the easiest school to
get in cuz I was like was we gonna take
me in a week I don't want to wait a year
so you went to so what did you major and
then I majored in psychology
oh me too man the matron is one of the
easiest words I was looking at I was
interested in it yeah it was the only
major that I could pick that was easy
enough where I could convince my parents
hey I could be I could get a PhD science
are you know I could I could convince
them that could be I'd still be a doctor
or some sort you know if I was actually
gonna go into psychiatry that's why that
was yeah really I kinda want it to - I
like listening to people's problems I
love how you do I just like to tell
people what to do in - oh yeah the
people's problems huh you like listen to
people's problems yeah I mean I'm it's
uh it's you know for me like you know I
don't know I've always been kind of I
wouldn't say like
empath maybe maybe yeah I'm very
empathetic I think you're pretty easy to
talk to like I never felt tense around
you or
weird like I just tell you whatever yeah
I'm the same way I mean it's just uh I
don't really I'm very in the moment I
you know I don't really you know when
I'm talking to people I mean you know
they have my full attention usually I'm
not really to off thinking about really
anything else you know because you can
kind of tell with when you're talking to
someone and you can kind of tell when
they have something else on their mind
and everything I mean for me I've always
been just very focused and kind of in
the moment yeah that's good you don't
have a TD I do actually I die I'm
actually diagnosed with ADHD oh I am
look but when you're in childhood you
guys are twins dude this was [ __ ] when
he was a kid psych major I don't know
how I graduated serious I still don't
know how I did it for this day me too
cuz I'm still learning things about
psychology that I learned in school and
I'm like oh man I should know this [ __ ]
well we got GPA and after you graduated
you got actually didn't graduate college
I had two semester left and I quit
really yeah I decided to move to LA I
graduated magna [ __ ] really damn bro I
graduate with the bare minimum GPA I
think it was like 2.3 GPA or sometimes
just barely made APA was but I think
okay so the thing about ADHD is that we
do have the ability to focus if we put
effort oh yes for sure into certain
things right but yeah I don't know like
its if we don't really see the reason or
if they we don't want to then we just
don't do it ya know yeah exactly I mean
for us it's kind of like it has to be
meaningful for us and if we latch on to
something that's you know of interest
and we really are into it and we're also
very good with our hands too because yes
you know that we have to focus where
stuff whatever digit it yeah we are
I wish Wheatley we had those fidget
spinners back then knew now yeah it's so
awesome that's crazy that the fitted
spinners was originally created for
people like that and just became like a
craze I know that means a lot of kids
have [ __ ] ADHD I bet you I bet you
they do yeah but it's like uh it's like
over diagnose but also under diagnosed
it's true I would just put like an
exercise bike in like these elementary
schools yeah these kids were fidgeting
it's like alright you get to sit in your
seat but you got a [ __ ] cycle like
just work that [ __ ] off or something
yeah exactly I don't think like I I feel
like it shouldn't really be like a like
negative thing like you know this is a
disorders there's more so we just
learned different
you know for sure I have a whole book
about it but it's it's basically the
whole take is like it's a superpower and
then they're saying that it's the hunter
gene so what so you know like whoever
has ADHD or just diagnosed with it it's
like saying you're a hunter living in a
farmer's world so yeah in and we're kind
of we feel kind of useless to society
because it's the way that it's
structured is more like a farmer like
I'm not saying like a real actual farmer
but then like someone that's in like
routine and day-to-day and whatever but
the people that have this gene tend to
be one excited and we're that we're kind
of like the white girl like in a horror
movie where we go towards the danger so
the way that it was I guess beneficial
as a society is you need those guys that
would be like Oh fire and in there like
I don't care and then you just run in
like a idiot and then just and that's
who I am yeah we're like uh or like the
one that goes okay I'm gonna go hunt see
you guys in three four days and you stay
like super happy where you're just
traveling and you yeah so it's a that's
really needed in that kind of oh yeah
Society yeah for sure but today you know
the way that the school system works
it's just for a different type of
personality yeah exactly you know I I
feel like we don't we don't we go to
school to learn but no one really ever
teaches us how to actually learn in
Genting you know to me you know how do
you actually study like how do you like
find interest in things
it was very like systemic and systematic
approaches like that tend to I mean it's
not gonna work for everybody yeah I mean
and also to like I just hate the way how
teachers are paid to so they they're not
gonna give a [ __ ] but then I'm motivated
and I'm motivated dude like I think I
care about the material people who we
sense it man yeah and then we don't care
about it either
yeah there's nothing to like incentivize
like teachers like it's still a job and
there's no incentives to it then what's
the whole point you know like you work
this job and it's not a dead-end job you
know I mean obviously like what they do
is very [ __ ] important but they're
not being compensated correctly for what
they do and I get it too cuz like its
demoralizing for them when the kids
don't give a [ __ ] and they come into
class and then they don't want to learn
[ __ ] so it's like they're just it's a
daycare wait you got a baby so many kids
do I saw this info graph
like hey like if you don't believe in
paying teachers a standard salary why
don't we just go buy you no babysitter
hours and was like you know $15 an hour
for a babysitter times you know 30 40
kids you know this is how much you
should you know X amount of hours like
you averaged out to like 300 thousand
dollars a year or something like that
you know and I mean I I see an argument
to that for sure
you know it's at the end of the day
we're investing in the future there was
this I forgot what I read it but it was
like some some kind of video where I
think Mark Wahlberg's mom is a teacher
right and he was he was kind of talking
about the point that we're talking about
right now but Matt kind of scroll
through some of the Instagram feeds go
to video s on Instagram and you know
there are a lot of people who do believe
that teachers are over compensated which
is [ __ ] crazy but it's like middle
America type of people were they're just
like well all they do is they work they
have summer school they don't work those
three months and you know that's their
mentality they go they they work from
night whatever like 8 a.m. to 3 p.m. and
that's it they get paid enough because I
work 14 hours and this is what I get
paid it's how you take work home you go
dumb what is who grades the [ __ ]
homework you dumbass yeah who creates
the syllabus who's who's creating the
curriculum you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] but
then there's a lot of people who don't
know that and they don't really
appreciate teachers like how much they
[ __ ] cuz I want it to be a teacher
yeah that was my original career choice
yeah so like when I saw that and in that
oh [ __ ] that comment had like a thousand
something like so I was like damn people
are that [ __ ] dumb they think they
teachers come in they punch in they
clock it in a [ __ ] clock out
it's like wow how [ __ ] dumb are
people in the United States in stick
they're consistently learning and
putting time towards you know what they
should be toward the subject that
they're teaching and all that stuff yeah
and I know a lot of teachers who use
their own money force for the [ __ ]
they don't get paid [ __ ] yeah not at all
you know yeah it sound crazy yeah that's
[ __ ] yeah I read that comment had
like a thousand something likes and
other people were disagreeing and
there's a handful of people that weren't
disagreeing but the fact that that comet
had so many likes bothered me I was like
do you really not know a you're an idiot
he goes I work I think he said something
too like oh I work at the factory I'm
you know you're making these cars
whatever what now you don't hear me
complaining I do actual real work and
it's what it's so odd what people
consider real work it's like you have to
be bleeding and dirty yep yeah I try not
to judge unless I've walked into that
person's shoe - yeah you know I try not
to make those assumptions either you
know and I think I will assume and they
you know they try to compare them to
themselves and yeah it's just a weird
thing like I never understood this word
this concept of because I worked harder
I should get paid more it's like no yeah
you work harder but you didn't work
smarter you don't get paid based on your
physical effort you get paid based on
what you bring to the [ __ ] table
where you deliver exactly yeah and a lot
of people don't understand that Magel I
worked hard
oh great Doug you also work like a
dumbass doesn't that sound I mean that's
just entitlement right yeah because they
have the choice to find another job they
have the choice this is this is a
[ __ ] free ass country man like what
why are you so bitter that's what I
don't understand yeah it's uh if you
want a career change if you want to get
paid better if you think being a teacher
is better than what you're doing then
why don't you become a teacher like that
give it such an easy job then maybe you
should do it yeah yeah that's the best
you see the best argument if that's what
you think then go for it psych roads
open for you be my guest tube like I'll
let you run my class of 50 kids specific
in California because these classes are
hyper impacted now it's like a ghetto -
yep in the ghetto cuz they pay good yeah
they also have the fear of [ __ ] dying
in I saw this video clip of this kid he
was this this teacher the substitute
teacher was writing stuff on the board
and he was a blood so whatever it was a
see he made him switch to a B so he goes
nah he's on now you can't do that [ __ ]
your home and you gotta put that [ __ ]
into a beat
Wow so it was like class had to be blast
you know me so he made him erase all the
C's and made it into a wall yeah and
that's like some real [ __ ] that these
teachers had to deal with like right it
was like what the fun are you allowed to
beat kids at school in that case it's
okay you know like you're just in a
different world you know the high school
I went to I went to you have you seen
Dangerous Minds yeah about that my
school was based off of oh that
they didn't film it there no it was it
was basically about so I went to CARLMAN
High School and so up in it's in the
suburbs like it's in a very nice area in
Dana Carvey went in tourists went to our
school he wasn't he's an alumni and
everything like as Dangerous Minds the
book was actually based off of a
teacher's experience from Carlmont high
school because [ __ ] I guess what
happened was they you know it's you know
most of the kids like I was a half the
kids were like from the suburbs like you
know you know upper middle class like
white everything but then the the other
half of the school was bused in from
East Palo Alto
I forgot whatever reason was maybe like
I don't know if it's because they didn't
have a high school there or whatever but
yeah it was majority it was just very
interesting to kind of see like you know
these two different worlds kind of like
you know clashing and everything but it
was it was crazy I mean overall like my
my high school experience was pretty
good but we've had we had like three
riots like you know during my time there
it was so interesting how 31 now so they
separate did they separate like the
busting kids with the summer kids no no
no but this is what I will say though I
mean it was interesting because after
like you know whenever a riot happened
right then they would separate the
lunches so they're like hey we're gonna
do split lunches but we're not exactly
sure how they figured out how to split
people and I will at the time like I
wasn't really aware of that so okay we
have to you know I'm in I'm in lunch one
versus lunch today you know they're like
protecting the suburb kids I had that I
don't know if that I thought I can't I
can't confirm or deny to be honest I
mean because at the time I just wasn't
really like I was aware of those sort
sort sort of they would have a reason
right it's at our high school
Mexicans against Blacks really yeah that
is crazy yeah and then of course there's
gang fights and there's just individual
fights and there's just people beating
teachers and it was [ __ ] nuts man
well I went to Gardena high and in the
second one seconds going went to a smart
couple by now mark apples one of the
best schools ever nice and it it was
because our generation was so [ __ ]
bad that they had to put a lot of focus
and that's what tends to happen right
like some schools are so [ __ ] bad and
then everyone puts a lot of focus there
yeah and then they change [ __ ] up but we
used to have a PSA at the mark Campbell
High School it would play on the local
TV
and it would show like how it decrepit
our [ __ ] pulse and it was based there
trying to get funding oh wow yeah but
then yeah I mean Gardena high was even
worse man that one was we had a police
station inside the high school there
were it was like the number three
biggest drug-dealing school in
California damn yeah locked up you know
what's crazy like maybe two years after
I graduate it's like something I forgot
maybe it was another riot or something
that happened but like I like they made
the students wear their ID cards around
their necks
oh [ __ ] had to identify every student
and stuff too so it's like yeah man
that's it that's something but people
don't understand like some of the air
some of the schools in America or like
three third-world countries or jails
yeah it's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] man like
we had a police station in our school
because there would be kids being caught
with actual crimes or like hardcore
violence and [ __ ] like we had a cop
stationed inside the [ __ ] you know
what do you the administration building
there was a bench with handcuffs [ __ ]
like hang in there there's always a kid
or two there there would be three or
four bicycle cops just like rolling
around with the security and um my
friend was telling me like not like we
didn't have police coming into our
school every day and we're like man we
had a police station literally inside of
our school um yeah dude it was nuts
do it like Dobby just yeah it was it was
chaotic duders yeah it was crazy and
like you know my classmates would
disappear left or right I remember you
know one of my one of my friends is a
guy named Roberto is a Mexican guy sat
next to me in English class and then one
day he stopped showing up and when I
asked him what happened who oh he got he
got shot like nine times you know in his
car two weeks ago like oh crap and like
you know and that you know I would hear
these stories like you know multiple
times throughout my time throughout my
time like during high school so I'm like
wow this is [ __ ] is real yeah I'm not
you know I didn't grow up in the streets
or anything like that but it's just
really interesting to kind of like you
know see that hasn't it observers to it
proximity proximity was yes because
there's kids that grow up with no
[ __ ] idea like like you know they'll
grow up in a nice little town and
everyone says hi to each other and damn
they might see it on TV but they don't
know the how [ __ ] close that [ __ ] is
yeah you hear so many things you know
you hear there I mean I naturally I hung
out what you know a lot a lot of the
minority kids because you know I went
through you know a couple instances of
racism through the school and so
naturally you know I kow yeah Norco what
city you know what it's everywhere but
like I lived in San Carlos area I mean
it's a pretty now San Carlos listen
Carlos okay so if it's if San Jose is
right here yeah and San Francisco is
right here we're kind of like in the
middle of everything so you know so like
we're talking like Menlo Park like close
to Menlo Park close to you know all the
great khali palace no I don't believe so
no not Kappa
know Cal palace is closer to Daly City
so yeah more tour that cell separates
yeah yeah yeah so man that's crazy
it's just such a I thought NorCal was
hella liberal ass like it was liberal I
mean no I mean even looking back like
wow how did I go through those things I
mean I remember I was just at a movie
theater right and I walked by this like
just like an old white couple look like
a nice person but then as I'm walking by
them and this is this is me like a
freshman in high school too
I hear the old guy yella [ __ ]
[ __ ] and like what Dan so random I
never realized that yes or in I mean
this is an or town or Cal is like got a
big concentration of Asian so like yeah
I always gave like old people passes and
I'm like I'm gonna die soon I respect my
elders is okay it's okay I'm just like
gonna die there's a point changing your
opinion dude you'll die with your
[ __ ] ideals to life so I just let it
go there's a young person bothers me
more yeah right more crazy
yeah well guys that's actually the end
of this podcast we usually braaap to
7:45 but we normal so solid
[ __ ] down with Sun I know that
was a good one yeah man well guys you
could catch us on Spotify iTunes podcast
and any type of audio platform out there
leave questions and comments in the
YouTube video below Benny where can they
find you obviously next shark but yeah I
mean if you want to follow me it's just
benny lu b en and why l uo people just
like to switch the oh you know you
well how do you pronounce that in the
Asian way well if you want to legit ways
law okay but then I used to say just loo
I liked luge's it was hard as [ __ ] yeah
but yeah check out next shark it's
definitely uh especially on JK news use
a lot of their articles and stuff man
and you know watch checking news first
and then you can click one other heart
please yes news we will see you guys
next time peace thank you very much